so leading up to the fight he talked a
lot of trash man not just
about me but he talked about my family
and he talked about
um kind of making fun of my last name
you know and i got emotional man i never
dealt with the situation like that
and it was a big fight it was my first
time on pay-per-view
um i was coming off a big win and then
all of a sudden i get this pay-per-view
spot
that that was you know the future fight
there was a lot in the line there and um
in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast
zoom edition we have the asian sensation
himself
man from wound socket rhode island
kicking the name people on the
[ __ ] face we have andre
how have you been my friend i'm doing
good man i'm doing good despite
everything going on
in the world you know i still feel
blessed and
and um i'm doing well anyway so you
signed up recently to
a new fight promotion right yes yes i
did
which which promotion is that it's not
ces though you didn't go back there
no i didn't i didn't end up going back
to ces i was supposed to but then the
fight got cancelled due to covey that's
when kobe
just started you know and um my fight
got cancelled from that
so i was on the shelf for a little bit
and then um
once they started doing shows again i
was even trying to put my name in
anywhere i didn't even care you know and
even the ufc like i knew they were
looking for fighters so i was just
trying to like
stay on weight all the time training all
the time and then
after searching a little bit we found
xfc um
i've heard xfc before actually like when
i first started fighting
i used to see them on um they used to be
a channel called
hd net and and hd net used to show
all the mma fights they used to have all
the mma shows it was a huge like
mma um channel on directv
and and comcast and all that so i
remember them i was just like man where
they've been they had a couple shows
in brazil in america they had great
shows too
um produced a lot of great fighters that
went on to bellator pfl
and even the ufc so i was like you know
what
i'm going to hit him up and um i had my
uh
my manager aka my wife
uh yeah put up the matchmaker and um
yeah we just i actually filled out a
tryout form because it was for trials
because they're
i guess like they were coming back with
a big boom you know they haven't had a
show for like two years and
they're coming back strong so i i filled
out something to try out and i was just
like wait
maybe maybe there's a better way to do
this and we just hit the matchmaker up
and
um started doing business right there
and then boom two days later on the main
event
and signed a three fights contract with
them yeah why would you sign a tryout
form dude like you already at the ufc
i'm pretty sure they're not gonna say no
they're like what the [ __ ] why is this
guy
filling out this [ __ ] form for like
you know i
um you know it was like two years since
i fought you know and
i just didn't know where i was at and i
was coming off for two losses being
released by ufc man
i was willing to do anything i didn't
care yeah
what was that like um getting cut from
the ufc because i know that
uh especially after you defended your
title right when you're at
ces you literally said i want to be in
the ufc and the next thing i know you're
in the [ __ ] ufc
and then um i mean you had it kind of
rough at the ufc then you got cut like
what was that what did that feel like
man of course it hurt it hurt a lot you
know um
it hurt even more knowing that i'd be
you know i i felt like i could have did
so much better than the ufc
you know i was two and five in the ufc
but i could have easily been
five and two um just uh little mistakes
on my end that that cost me the
the fights and you know i realized that
and i accepted the fact
that uh they let me go and you know they
can't keep a losing fight on the roster
but i wish it would have gave me another
fight because you know you see these
people they they
it's usually three fights in a row and
you get cut i lost two in a row
and i had one more fight left in my
contract so i was kind of
kind of hoping to praying that they gave
me another shot but you know sean shelby
the matchmaker
he hit up my manager at that time other
manager and he was like
you know uh we're gonna have to let him
go the roster is getting filled and
that's when they were signing a whole
bunch of people because they had the
contender series going on
and um they were like but andre gets a
couple wins
and he gets him himself back on track
he can be back you know so um that gave
me a lot of hope
i mean you definitely entered the 135 i
mean your division is [ __ ] stacked
like it
is [ __ ] crazy everybody's a [ __ ]
killer in that division
so you just never know what's gonna
happen like every time i watch
like your weight division specifically
i'm like doc
who the [ __ ] is gonna die today that's
what i feel like
yeah man the 135 division is just so
explosive
so fast and at the same time um
they carry all they carry the knockout
power you know
with the kicks and the punches so it's
it's a really dangerous division
and um everyone's getting better and the
sport's just evolving
and um i was you know of course man
like bro like when i lose a fight
even before i got to the ufc even before
i was a pro
when i was an amateur when you lose a
fight you could talk to any fighter man
it's like
you know we can talk about when we win
it's the greatest feeling in the world
nothing compares it like doesn't matter
what stage you fight at
winning is like what we chase that's the
goal that we chase
man that's that's a high that we us
fighters chase
but when you lose man we're not just sad
that day that week it it carries on
until like we get our next fight booked
because
like now he's like oh now i can redeem
myself i can get back to training
uh for a fight and and i can you know
you're only as good as your last fight
you know and if you lost your last fight
that's always going to be in the back of
your head so
you know i lost i didn't just lose a
fight i got cut by
the ufc i worked like 10 years to get
there
and it was my dream and
i was obsessed with being in the ufc and
yeah i got cut
i just i lost my job man and i i felt it
for a little bit
you know i was down and out for a little
bit and
but um it was all learning curve man
i i look at it as experiences
and and i was i'm kind of relieved that
it all happened now because
i'm not only a better fighter now
because of that i'm a smarter one too
so yeah so when you i mean when you
first your first
ufc fight actually uh all your losses
were by decision like i think one of the
things about you like you don't get
knocked out
that's like that's like your thing i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is about you
but you don't you have a lot of heart
right
so i mean if somebody's going to go
ahead and fight you they're going to
have to put your lights out which has
never happened
it has never happened you know yeah man
i'm
13 and uh 14 and 8 um
[Music]
and my overall i have like 50 fights
including amateur including muay thai
fights including boxing fights i have 50
fights amateur and pro
and i've never been i've lost fights you
know but i've never been finished
and um i do take a lot of pride in that
you know i
i take a lot of pride in that i'd rather
go to sleep than tap
i'd rather um you know if i get knocked
out you got to put me away
not you can't just rock me i won't i
won't go out that way you got to really
put me to sleep
so that that's always my mindset um not
just in the cage man but
that's kind of how i am in real life you
know i
i just i just keep on going man you
can't knock me down if
you knock me down you can't keep me down
who's the first person that you fought
in the ufc
what was his name it was um albert
morales man albert morales that's right
they had a couple buddies that were uh
set to fight him uh after because he got
cut from the ufc as well you gotta come
from ufc too
and yeah and you lost that one by
decision i actually thought you had that
one
and once again it could have been my
fight i made a i made a
decision to take him down when it was
just a decision like i'm not a wrestler
i'm a striker everybody knows that
but um you know when you're tired
and i took that fight nine days notice
you know and i had to lose about 25
pounds to make weight for that fight god
so um you know i was drained i was tired
i was training the whole time but
when you do a weight cut like that
you're gonna be drained so it was just
my emotions
um kicking in and and my mental state
wasn't there and i went for the takedown
and it kind of failed me
and it cost me to fight you know for the
i mean so one of the biggest things that
you're
obviously known for it's not one of the
best things on earth is the shadow
mallee fight right
and obviously sean o'malley right now is
in a position where a lot of people
aren't liking him as much you know which
i'm pretty sure
obviously because of his mouthpiece his
last loss to cheeto um
he didn't really take it well on the
chin at all you know
um when you took on that fight with sean
o'malley it was a pretty big deal right
he's an up-and-coming young prospect at
the time and he still is now
but you know he has a big mouthpiece on
him and you guys had a lot of drama
coming up to that fight
um when you when you fight somebody like
that right and we'll get into obviously
what happened in the fight after
leading up to the fight like do you do
you do you actually like dislike this
dude
yeah i do i do um not so much now it's
like whatever now you know
that's just the way he is but um so
leading up to the fight he talked a lot
of trash man
not just about me but he talked about my
family
and he talked about um he kind of making
fun of my last name
you know and i got emotional man i never
dealt with the situation like that and
it was a big fight it was my first time
on pay-per-view
um i was coming off a big win and then
all of a sudden i get this pay-per-view
spot
that was uh you know the featured fight
there was a lot in the line there and um
he was just talking so much crap about
me how can you mix
and like the thing is he has such a big
fan base
and a bunch of like people just just
riding him you know like
a bunch of yes man all his fans and no
matter what he says they ride with him
and and like i will get messages every
day like hundreds of messages and
on my posts like people making fun of me
for for being a good dad
like yeah how you gonna make fun of
somebody for
for taking care of their children the
the you know to the best of their
ability like i try every day to be the
best dad that i can be
and he turned that into a joke somehow
and mixed it in with
uh some racial stuff you know and
and um that got me really emotional man
and
a lot of people don't know i might have
said it a little bit before
and i posted it in my instagram before
but um i actually tore my mcl
day the day after i
signed that fight i turned my mcl in
practice
it was a day right before new year's i
will never forget it and um
then we had that fight and i just stuck
to it so that's why my cardio wasn't the
best
that fight too no excuses you know but
that's the truth
and um if you go back and look at that
post
you see um him and his team did homework
they knew that i was an emotional
fighter
they knew you know they had a whole game
plan on me
that's why they chose me to call me out
that's why they called the ufc was like
listen we want this guy
you know he's like dana white's pet they
want this guy and they picked me
and they did their homework they they
got into my head
and they knew that i had a torn mcl i
don't know how they knew that
but they had some they must have saw
something online i had a knee brace on
or something and then
um in the weigh-ins his coach
um he was like we know about your knee
[ __ ]
and that oh oh [ __ ] i i had a poker face
but i was just like
oh [ __ ] like how the [ __ ] did you find
no yeah
i don't know how he found out uh maybe
maybe through pictures my brace you know
i
i was teaching at a school at that time
and i was wearing the brace maybe i
wasn't as careful as i should have been
you know what i mean and um yeah you
literally said that at williams we know
about your name [ __ ]
and i was just like damn that's why like
if you watch the fight again right at
the opening about he he attacks my
my legs he tries to keep my knee you
know and um
they did their homework and they did a
well job with that yeah
if you could run that fight back what
would you have done differently i mean
shot o'malley as a fighter he's very
unorthodox he's
he's very weird you know like in in for
to his advantage too
his his uh lexicon of strikes are up
there like he does
a lot of stuff that other fighters don't
do i mean clearly we've seen in your
fight
and also the cheeto verified you know
people are saying this guy's made out of
sugar cubes
because he keeps [ __ ] breaking his
[ __ ] legs and [ __ ] you know so
i mean what would you have done
differently man i i probably would have
um attacked a little more in the first
round
you know i thought that um he kind of
wear himself
out throwing all the slashy stuff and my
defense is good you know that
that's kind of kind of something that i
pride myself into i have good defense
it's not easy to hit me it's not easy to
get a clean shot on me although he did
get a clean shot on me
it's not that easy for other people to
do it you know with kicks or punches so
i was just trying to dodge everything
and block everything because i knew i
was very adorable
even if he kicked i knew that um
it wouldn't hurt me as much and and it
didn't you know everything hit my elbows
my knees my legs
and um i wish i would have just been a
little more aggressive in the pocket
and um go to his body a little more and
uh
kind of put out a better output you know
but i knew what my cardio was at that
time too and it wasn't the best you know
i
i wasn't in the best shape that fight so
it's easy to say you know
i i will go back and i'll go back and
fight the same way i would have just
stood up
and i would've won the fight yeah i mean
and and um
but really man my mind really just
wasn't there he caught me with a really
clean shot
in the first round and i literally
really didn't know where i was
in the middle of the second round i
finally woke up and then
i finally got get this kid to where i
want want want him at you know in the
third round on the floor i want a pound
on his face
so that's what i tried to do you know
did you know he was hurt i knew he was
hurt but i mean i didn't know he was
that hurt
and because i i don't even know where
exactly he
what either fractured something or he it
was did he fracture his ankle or what
happened but did
was it because you you blocked one of
his kicks i don't know how it happened
though
yeah i blocked i blocked his kick he
tried to question mark kicked me
and um he kicked me right now right in
the forearm you know usually
usually my forearm would break if you're
gonna kick it you know
i i think i made a steal maybe i don't
know um
but he yeah he's he's not too
durable everybody's seeing that yeah
yeah yeah i mean we saw it in the cheeto
fight and what happened
yeah but that was the same spot though
this podcast is brought to you by purple
my friends
what are you sleeping on if you're not
sleeping on a purple mattress
well the back aches must be lovely you
must love sleeping in pain
you might as well just take your back
out on a date and say here
pay for the dinner yourself walk
yourself home and no boom boom for you
that's what you're doing to yourself did
you know that for a fat chunk of our
lives we're actually
sleeping so why are you skipping out
on making sure that your back has
pleasure party in the front
party in the back relax all day i love
my purple mattress because guess what
comfort is reinvented with that
specialty grid that purple has
and it's also backed by science son
rocket scientist has
actually developed the technology in the
mattress itself to help
you sleep better well guess what purple
really is comfort for an uncomfortable
world right now you'll get 10
off any order of 200 or more go to
purple.com
gb10 and use promo code gb10 that's
purple.com
gb10 promo code gb10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more purple.com
gb10 promo code gb10 terms apply
i told i meant i messaged cheeto like
you owe me 30
in your purse bro because i warmed that
up for you i won that
feeling i really told him i was like yo
you'll be 30
he didn't respond yeah i hope we saw it
that's [ __ ] funny man yeah i mean
after that happened um
i mean you definitely got a lot of flack
for that part right oh man
it was bad it was all over the place
people were talking about your fight iq
um and i remember that day i like i
messaged you and i was just kind of
curious because number one
i always want people to know even when
like for example like i have opinions on
fighters right or whatever
i'm not a fighter i don't know what a
fighter goes through in that cage
the best thing i know is like hard
sparring and everything else like that
but
when a fighter is in a moment like that
we can see it from the outside and say
hey this is what this person should have
done
however we're not the ones who have a
[ __ ] knee to our [ __ ] mouth and a
fist to our face
so it's hard to kind of assess what goes
on so you know
when i remember when i was asking you
you know what happened there you were
telling me that you were kind of dazed
like you just
you couldn't really see it at that
moment because you kind of had tunnel
vision at that point right i was dazed
and tired
yeah you know it's one thing to be days
but i was tired too
um like i said i couldn't really do
everything i wanted to do in camp
because of my knee
so you know we found ways around that so
made it to the fight healthy i had a
great team behind me
but i was dazed and tired you know if
you watch that first round you caught me
with a clean shot
right to the jaw yeah i didn't drop
people say that he dropped me but i did
not drop when you drop your knee hits
the ground
my hand hit the ground and then i got
right back up and he just unloaded with
me
he unloaded on me i was against the cage
and he was just throwing everything in
the kitchen sink at me
and some of it went through you know and
that's what made me a little more dizzy
and then as the fight went on i got
tired and
and you mix those two together man i
i was just going through instinct and my
instinct is fight
not winning that way you know what i
mean yeah
i'm a fighter did you have trouble like
uh hearing your corner
no i didn't i heard i heard them say
elbows elbows
stand up andre stand up andre
i think they said that you know i mean
like i it was just a weird place at that
time man i was so dazed and confused
but um i'm pretty sure i know my corner
they would have told me to stand up yeah
yeah yeah yeah so after
after that fight um i guess like i'm
kind of curious about the mentality of a
fighter right especially
i mean it's hard enough kind of like
being in the cage and having to deal
with this but also there's like social
media now there's all these people who
are like talking [ __ ] about people who
can't do what you do
right so i mean obviously people were
going on a terror there was
even some of your teammates had opinions
about that stuff on a public platform
right
i think um rashad evans like rashad
evans
was criticizing you publicly on ufc like
like how did you deal with that
and you know that's what people see you
know when big figures like that
they say stuff and it hurt man it hurt a
lot um
i had to talk with sugar after that uh
rashad evans and it was cool but
but like i get it man i made the mistake
so i own up to it and that's what i
signed up for
and i should have done better than that
but at the same time people really don't
know how i was feeling they don't know
what i went through
unless you were in that camp with me you
know people that were with that came
with me they saw
how i pushed through with my name and i
made it to the fight
and um i was dazed and i was
rock and all that but after the fight
with everyone you know really
hating on me and and talking [ __ ] to me
and saying that i got
i'm the stupidest fighter in the ufc
stupid this fighter in history
you know you hear that so many times you
start to believe it you know
and um man i i fell into a i was sad for
a little bit
you know i'm not gonna say i was
depressed but i was really sad i wasn't
myself i was moody
i wasn't the best dad at that time i
wasn't the best husband at that time
when when that all that was going on you
know and then
um i and like i said you know
when i said before you know i got i got
my next fight booked
all right it's time to forget about that
it's time to focus
on this fight and i ended up winning
that fight
so um you know of course
i i still get messages till today for um
o'malley fight but i just laugh at it
now yeah um
people make mistakes man and if you
don't learn from it then that's your
mistake
i'm gonna try and learn from all my
mistakes um
and that's what i'm doing yeah for in
your opinion as a fighter right and
um you know when you take like these
decision losses right and and then you
kind of go back and you look at this
footage
um i guess if i were to ask you uh to
like
if you had to critique your own fighting
and like the way you fight
um in these losses what is something
that you feel like you can improve on
my fight iq okay definitely and that's
why i've been working on these past two
years
with my fight iq um with my team
american top team
american top team now i've been with
them for the last two years
and that's what we've really been
working on you know there's a lot more
technique
in the training rather than just trying
to take someone's head off
rather just than just trying to wrestle
and dominate somebody
there's a lot more technique to the
training now and
um there's so many coaches at att now
too that
they can really focus on you and and
like if you have a question
they'll slow down and break it break it
down for you and they'll stay the night
you know they'll
they'll schedule a session with you and
and um
you'll get it down so i've been working
a lot on my fight iq
and just trying to visualize a little
more and
study a little more tape not just of my
opponents but myself
and be cautious of what they're good at
you know um i really didn't i really
didn't do that before
you know i just went in and i fought um
how come how come you never did that
before i was never really taught that
okay no i was um i uh
when i was up north before i moved to
florida you know my coaches did that for
me
all my coaches my pops did that and my
boxing coach
but then when i moved down to florida to
um to train with the black zillions
there were so many
studs in the room that a lot of the
coaches didn't have time to do that for
you
so you kind of just taught how to be
tough and taught how to
go in and just fight on instinct and
which i really appreciate
you know i i learned a lot from that too
i that's why my defense is good that's
why
i've never been finished you know
because my heart plus
plus i've been through that in the
training room so it's nothing new to me
with someone trying to smash my face
when i'm almost knocked out and stuff
you know like
that's nothing new to me but when i
moved to att i just saw that there was a
lot more um
they slowed things a lot down a lot more
and it was more strategic
yeah fight you know and and um
definitely if you watch all my ufc
fights that i i lost
besides like two besides one maybe
all my fights were because of me you
know um i go to mexico
i fight the mexican star i dropped him
three times with a jab
and i'm taunting him instead of
finishing him you know i mean i'm having
way too much fun in there it's not the
time to have fun
right it's time to go in there get a
second check and take care of your
family you know and
and um i think i was real immature at
that time
um inside the cage and outside the cage
you know i'm gonna admit it you know i i
wasn't handling things personally a lot
uh that that good either either you know
and and
that you need to have a good foundation
and you need to be set that's that's why
all the great fighters they have a great
foundation they're focused
they're 100 focused and um i can't say i
was that
so that's another lesson i learned yeah
so
for you you you grew up fighting your
whole life then because you said your
father is your coach
and um do you have any other fighters in
your family besides you or is it just
you
no i'm just my dad and my grandpa he
fought but um i actually didn't start
fighting until i was 18
oh out of high school yeah i before that
i was a soccer player
and i had dreams of playing for college
one day and i also played basketball
i played for the high school i played
travel so i was an athlete
but i never did boxing or kickboxing i
always wanted to i was always intrigued
by it
but um i never got the chance to do it
because i was just so focused on other
sports
and then um when i got out of high
school
um i started training at an mma gym
and then that was history yeah so what
made you like kind of gravitate towards
fighting because fighting is is [ __ ]
tough man like
i don't know yes yeah it really is tough
man i
uh i have a really really um
i have a story you know and and it's not
the most pleasant story
um but uh you might even know about it
but you know i had a
in high school i had my wife now she was
pregnant at that time
when we first met and um i was having
the baby on the way so i was just like
damn i have i got recruited by like
seven schools
for college you know for soccer and and
um i'll go with my dream
but i decided to put those those dreams
aside so that i can work full-time
and and try and support um you know
my my girlfriend at that time and my my
son
i was having a son so i put those dreams
aside and i decided to work at the home
depot full-time
and um there was an mma gym down the
street
and i was curious and then one of my
friends said hey do you want to try it
i was just like yeah sure and then we
went together
one time and then the rest was history i
tried my first class
i was just like wow this is what i want
to do you know and
um and that's what i did
i did it every day you know i'll go
train after work
um i couldn't afford the tuition so i i
talked to the owner and he gave me an
opportunity
i did this for about three years i after
training every day i would vacuum the
floors
uh mop the mats clean the yoga room
clean the
bathrooms the showers the toilets so
practice would be over at like eight but
i'd be i'll be there till 9 45 and i'll
get home at like at like
10 30 every every night you know monday
through friday and i did that for about
three years
um that was now still amateur and i
wasn't even the pro yet you know i
didn't even have any uh pro fights yet
so so your dad didn't coach money
huh your dad didn't coach you at first
then he was coaching me at that time
but we used that gym because we didn't
have a gym so we used that
that gym and um yeah i'm just real
thankful for the opportunity sorry
and um you know nine months after
my son was actually born he he actually
passed away he had skin disease
yeah i was really young i was um 19 when
he passed away i was 18 when i had him
you know when we had him and he was 19.
i was 19 when he passed away he had
a disease called epinephrine
and um it was really taxing on him um
just a young couple trying to take care
of our baby you know and
um after that man i just
that's why i i felt like i went into a
depression a little bit because i know
how
what depression feels like you know
because i went through that but then
like
mma kind of saved me and that's when i
really went hard at mma you know
that was kind of my sanctuary um
and and that's when i started going pro
and started fighting
wow do you i mean that's crazy i didn't
i didn't know you had a i had a kid that
passed away so i was like well
how old are you kids now because they
look pretty young so you
wow you had a kid so you were so you had
a kid
as a teenager and then did you and did
that kind of motivate you to kind of
work harder
that motivated me to just take care of
my family and i come from a small town
with soccer rhode island
and um you got to work you got to work
to make your money you got to work to
make a living and
i had to work to support my family and
that's what i decided to do
and then i got into fighting and i was
like oh i'm gonna work and do training
you know and then
my son passed away and then i was just
like i'm just gonna train
yeah so your dad um
was your dad training people when when
you were growing up too or
was it something that he got into he got
into it he got back into it because i
told him that i was going to be a
fighter
and he wasn't happy with it because he
always tried to keep me away from it
you know he didn't
i'll tell you the truth the the the real
reason they want me to fight he want me
to break my nose
he didn't want me to mess up my
appearance he didn't want me to have
black eyes he didn't want me to have a
broken face
and um he didn't want me to be ugly he
said
you know and um he was like no you're my
son you're too handsome to fight
and then when i finally broke it down to
i was 18. i'm 18 at the time you know
i'm on my own
and i got my you know i got my own stuff
going on
and he was like all right well if you're
gonna fight i gotta train you because i
don't want you get your ass kicked
my dad my dad is he's just like he's
very
very tough so he's like i don't want you
to get your ass kicked so i'm gonna
train
so he trained me and um before we
continue my friends this podcast is
brought to you by
ship station have you heard of ship
station if you haven't and you have an
online business and you're selling
things what are you
doing ship station is a necessity
i use shipstation all the time if i'm
shipping out products selling anything
whether it's merch or you have a small
business
you need to get on this let me tell you
why shipstation is so freaking amazing
no matter what you're selling amazon
etsy your own website ship station
funnels all your orders into
one simple interface that you can manage
from anywhere
even your cell phone with shipstation
small businesses can now access the same
rates
usually reserved for fortune 500
companies
without the contracts or commitments
this is super
important i need to have all the stuff
connected when you're shipping things
through different mediums
if you have to constantly open up
different apps to get to things are you
really going to do it
shipstation makes everything so freaking
easy
if you have a small business you're
shipping anything out you have to
you will not regret it it's my favorite
thing to use i kid you not well guess
what
ship more in less time just use my offer
code geniusbrain to get a
60 day free trial that's two months free
of no hassle
stress free shipping just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page
and type in geniusbrain that's
shipstation.com enter offer code
geniusbrain and make
ship happen we we had a good
run together we had a really good run
together and he's still a part of
my my team of course you know he'll call
me all the time and
try to give me uh things to train in and
game plans and breakdowns of my
future opponents so it's team sukum
always baby yeah do you the
was it kind of hard for you to go away
from your dad and go to another team
no it wasn't to be honest um we clashed
heads a lot it
actually kind of
at one point it ruined our relationship
you know and even now if we start
talking fighting
we start training each other i can't
promise you that we won't
clash heads yeah just like that
because dad always knows better right
exactly and i'm like dad no
this is different now no but i've been
in the cave
i got like 50 i don't care i'm your dad
you got to do this this will work
and that's kind of how it is you know
but he's my dad
he's just looking for the best he's just
looking for the best of me he wants me
to be the best
fighter i can be and the most important
thing is i know he's really proud of me
you know i know he
bothered me he tells me all the time and
it shows you know he's always bragging
about me so
he's just proud of me and he wants me to
be the best i can be that's it
did you ever like get into a lot of
fights as a kid or is this just
something that you just
got you gravitated towards because you
walked into that mma gym
you know that that's what separates me
from a lot of uh
people i think that's why because when i
went to the mma gym i saw these guys and
i talked to them like
have you ever been in a fight before you
got in a fight or started doing this and
you're like no i've never been in the
fight at all
and um yeah i got a lot of scraps going
up man
um that's all i did really i had a hot
head
and um i got in a lot of fights
uh a lot of people wanted problems with
me sometimes and i had no choice but but
to defend myself
and fight so i wasn't afraid to fight
i'm not afraid of fight you know when i
go in the cage it's just natural for me
yeah yeah yeah i mean that's so because
fighting is such a
it's like a scary concept like even for
me like growing up you know
everybody had to throw fist here and
there right but fighting against
somebody who's trained is completely
different
i i remember you know when i just
started kickboxing right and i'm like
this [ __ ] could read everything
that i'm gonna throw and he is socking
me in the face
and you know that's like a very scary
thought you know
because when you do when you street
scrap with somebody usually it's two
people who don't know how to fight and
you're just swinging to see whatever the
[ __ ] happens
when we get tired of like 30 seconds
yeah then they break it up
or someone quits okay and then you know
you're sparring with people they're
sweeping you they're socking you in the
face
punching you before you even know what
the [ __ ] you're doing and i'm like yo
what am i in the matrix like what the
[ __ ] is going on right now you know you
know
you know what david i felt the same way
when i first started training at 18
i was getting i was getting beat up by
all these guys and
i didn't know what to do back especially
jiu jitsu i was getting tied up like a
pretzel
yeah i didn't know anything at all you
know i i thought that was tough i
thought i was
big and bad but no i wasn't man i was
getting i was getting beat up
and hey you came a long way though you
got your
credit like i said your videos
this is [ __ ] hard though man like
that's one of those things that's hard
for me to like wrap my head around
uh obviously i haven't given it like a
full try yet but it's
it's hard man like jiu-jitsu is like
chess like i feel like that's definitely
a smart man's like martial arts like you
can't just walk in and expect
like even the strongest people they get
tied up they get choked out
you know it's it's so difficult and when
i watch fighters like
or even like grapplers and wrestlers
right like every time i watch habib like
when he retired i was so sad
like i'm still sick i'm still sad about
it because because every time i watch
him i want to see what this guy can do
or what somebody is going to try to do
he's such a great champion yeah because
i remember i just watched the uh the
poirier
uh interview with joe rogan and then
poirier was like yeah he's strong he's
not
he's like but you know i felt people who
are stronger but he was like it's not
because of his strength he just knows
what you're going to do next and he
knows where to position his weight
where you can't do anything and he goes
that's something new that i haven't
experienced and he goes that's the hard
part about habib
he just he's just controlling you
constantly you know
absolutely man i that's why some of
these wrestlers are so
successful when it comes to mma because
they know grappling already and then you
learn a little bit jiu jitsu with that
and all they got to do is learn uh be
committed and learn to stand up
and to be honest learning how to strike
is a lot easier than
learning how to um wrestle and do jiu
jitsu on the ground
you know with jiu jitsu it's like if you
want to be good at it you have to really
be committed to it
you know i'm talking four three four
five days a week
and then you'll slowly start getting
better at it you know you tell that to
ben askren dude this [ __ ]
striking
is is [ __ ] terrible god damn it
crazy yeah at one point he never needed
it you know
just take guys down in one fc and
bellator and just
and just do what he does man but you
know when you go to
higher levels like do you guys i'm not
gonna say higher levels
but you know when you get different
opponents like um ufc fighters that like
to scrap
and i've been there and done that and
have training partners that can mimic
ben asking
it's kind of different you know how do
you feel about um
because you're in the 135 if is michael
chandler
135 as well no he's not no he's 155.
he's 155. he's a big boy right he's kind
of small though
but you you trained with you was he at
att as well
no he was at the black zillions ah okay
okay
yeah and then yeah i did some training
with him
early we'll set that smile
hey man you know he's i'm happy for him
he he's
he's uh he's doing well
he's doing well and he's you know what
that i'm happy for him means that he's
[ __ ] this guy
nah not even man like you know we we got
into it
um a couple times in practice you know
and
he said some things to me like you know
i was a gym champion
and things like that like um oh but i'm
not gonna talk bad about the guy man
i i i wish i wish well for him he's uh
he's a great fighter
and and he shows in the cage you know
he's an
animal in the cage he's a beast in the
cage and um that's something i really
respect
of him because doesn't matter how he
looks in practice or
how he trains in practice he trains hard
but he trains a little different
yeah um like you know the whole group's
doing this thing and then he's doing
this thing
like that but you know it's all good
it's working for him
and now that um i'm working on myself
i realized that you know he was just
doing what was best for him
and uh it's working and good for him man
he's an animal in that cage
and i mean watching his ufc his ufc
debut was so weird because
it almost looked like he has been
fighting in the ufc his whole life
when he when he stepped into that cage
he looked like he owned that [ __ ]
octagon
and you know it's not like he was
fighting some [ __ ] chump dan hooker
is a monster
and when i was watching i said why does
dan hooker look nervous compared to
michael chandler it's his debut and he
looked like he was
born to do it and i think when i saw
that because i actually had my money on
dan hooker
i was like you know he's about to show
michael chandler what's up with
you know these ufc fighters who have
seen wars because you know are you you
know when people when i saw the uh dan
hooker and poirier fight that [ __ ] was a
banger it was all fireworks yeah michael
chan was gonna have some [ __ ] trouble
with this guy he was such a bigger reach
than him
and you know dan hooker's takedown
defense is great lo and behold
this fool knocks this [ __ ] out
i was sh shocked
my [ __ ] jaw dropped he you know he
has a great team behind him
and um that's the team that i used to
train at you know i have no ill will
towards um my old team you know and but
he they put a lot of time into him and
it's showing you know because he didn't
fight like that before but
now um his game-ness in the cage mixed
with his different skills that he's
learning at stanford mma
it's all showing man because he's an
explosive athlete like i said he's just
a beast other than lights and and he
knows how to
control that i think that's why he acted
like he owned the cage he
like he belonged in the ufc because he
he knew it and he saw it for a long time
he's just a
competitor you know yeah so what was it
like for you like
uh growing up in rhode island is there a
lot of asian people out there or
were you just kind of like one of the
few no there was there was a lot of
asian people out there
and that that's a big reason why i got
into a lot of fights
because i don't know how it is in
california during that time you know
we're about the same age
during that time growing up from you
know being like 10 to like
18. was there a lot of gang violence
like asian not asian gang violence
there's a [ __ ] ton of gang violence
that's that's all it was
right yeah i mean i mean yeah i think
just because it was
you know that's the thing like people
have a huge misconception about asian
people right when when they say asian
they just think we're all grouped up
together but yeah this is a huge ass
[ __ ] continent
you know what i mean and languages and
cultures all the like yo you
asian people like when people say like
yo asian people are racist
i'm like they they ain't worried about
you that chinese person is talking [ __ ]
about that vietnamese person
yeah exactly so where i grew up
at that time you know i wouldn't say so
it's like that right now but
you know sadly there was a lot of um
asian and asian gang violence
yeah you know and um i was i'm actually
from providence rhode island
okay and and then there's the rhode
island
right and these two the gang of
providence
did not get along with the gang wound
sake i'm talking about not just fighting
but
killings yeah you know and um
it was like that like my whole middle
school high school
you know life and then what happened was
my mom got a job closer to when soccer
so we ended up this providence kid
ended up moving to one socket and rhode
island is so small
i'm talking about it's probably the size
of fresno oh [ __ ] okay you know what i'm
saying
and so you know i i i started living in
wu saki and then and then people see me
around and some people know who i am i'm
cool
i play soccer with some of those guys
ready to play for the team
boom i have some friends already but the
guys that don't know me
they they're like where's this kid from
oh and then the word gets around i'm
from i'm from providence
so then automatically they assume you
know they know i'm not a gangbanger
because i i don't act like one
i wasn't like trying to be one but just
because i was from providence
people wanted to mess with me you know
and that that's where i got into a lot
of fights
um but you know all that all that stuff
happened and then
i ended up getting the respect you know
because i never backed down
from anybody and i was i was a good
athlete too so i got some respect from
that and now
some of those guys that you know there's
some of my my best friends
now so it's crazy how it works and
the crazy part is you know there wasn't
many loud people
doing mma at that time so think about
rhode island you know everybody's
rooting for me i'm talking about
everybody everybody asian um everybody
that knew me
so what i did was i kind of i think i
kind of brought those people together
i mean i brought providence in osaka
together because
those same rival gangs would show up to
the you know they couldn't be under a
building
under the same building because yeah
maybe some there'll be a fight or
gunshots or something
always happening like that but when i
started fighting when i started fighting
i noticed that
i see people from the same city from uh
different cities and different gangs
they all go and support me
under one building and there'll be no
fights there'll be no shootouts
there'll be no beef i literally be on
top of the cage and i'll see
like uh soccer gang member and the
promised gang member
just clapping for me after i won like
side by side
and and that was a really cool thing to
see you know i mean and um
i'm glad that i chilled out i'm really
glad that it chilled out yeah
well so if for you what made you like
not want to join a gang or anything else
like that because i felt like that was
hard for a lot of asian kids like if you
grew up around that [ __ ]
you know you were going to do it like i
never joined the game like i was too
much of a [ __ ]
you know but you don't get did you get
teased or not because i got teased a lot
and i even got like
beat up sometimes sucker punched and
picked on a lot because
i didn't want to be in a gang because i
wasn't in the best neighborhood either
and
i know your story and you didn't grow up
in the best neighborhood either so did
you get picked on for that too
yeah i mean definitely like it's it's
hard it's weird right because
you know when everybody's doing some as
a kid you want to be
involved in everything everybody else is
doing right but
i knew i was never about that life my
father was a pastor
you know i mean i was just a goofy ass
kid and the reason why i got away with a
lot of the stuff that i got to was
number one i'm like six foot one i was a
big kid
you know and also too i was really funny
so i got to
be able to joke around with them make
them laugh and stuff so they let me kick
it with them here and there
exactly and i got lucky because a lot of
these dudes saw me grow up when i was a
little kid
so a lot of like the og ogs would watch
after me it's like yo leave him alone
like he's like a
you know goofy ass kid some of them you
know they would try me i would just have
to get smacked a little bit
you know what was i gonna do these
[ __ ] will [ __ ] kill me
but they would they i mean they tried to
bring me to some of this stuff but after
a while i was like this isn't for me i
can't do this [ __ ] like i told the story
on this podcast like i remember the
first time
um i went to a house party and this dude
spit on the floor inside the house and
he spit on this dude's air force ones
and this guy looked at him and he just
goes
clean my [ __ ] shoe right and this
guy's like [ __ ] you i clean that [ __ ]
and this dude didn't know
lo and behold this dude's [ __ ]
strapped he stands up like 10 other
dudes are strapped up
sit up and they all put they all whip
out the straw i'm like damn this is not
and i'm sitting here this goofy-ass kid
with these coke bottle glasses like
i'm gonna die like yo what the [ __ ] am i
doing here this podcast is brought to
you
by babel my friends my favorite
language learning app you need to
level up and learn another language i'm
already bilingual
well what's wrong with being a
trilingual sexual baby
that's me i'm learning espanol my
friends
it's me baby babel is probably one of
the
easiest language learning apps i've ever
been on specifically because like
they kind of teach you language in the
way that most people speak it right
so when i was in high school they would
teach us through these books that
just didn't really teach you how to
speak colloquially
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language
on the go unlike the infamous language
classes you took in high school babel
designs their courses with practical
real world conversations in mind
and things you'll get to use every day
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and
accents super important muy importante
my friends
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com
and use promo code gb that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code gb for an extra three months free
babble language for life it's kind of
crazy yeah
i didn't want to be involved in that
that type of stuff but it was hard
because like you know you're the goofy
kid so
sometimes too they would just make fun
of me poke fun at me and i just had to
sit there and laugh and take it
so i you know it was weird because i
wanted the protection but i wasn't
i just didn't have the hard enough to be
in a gang and it's like it's not like i
could do it you know
yeah yeah same with me i think the
juniors they messed around with me a lot
you know
the og's never messed around with me
they respected my dad my dad was really
well respected and um i i could
i could say i had good guidance from my
father you know he um
he always told me to be a leader not a
follower and
he actually signed me up to a private
school in middle school
to keep me away from all that so i went
to a private school
in middle school and um but i would come
home to the same stuff
you know i'm saying like i'll be i'll be
at this private school but you know i
still live at the same place so i'll
come home with the same stuff and
i'll face i face the same problems like
these kids you know go to the park and
i'm getting i made fun of
people picking fights with me people
call me rich boy cause i got fake polo
socks on because my mom wants me to look
decent you know
but um you know it was kind of tough
growing up in that aspect
but sports saved my life you know once
my dad
put me on the soccer team once he put me
on the basketball team
it was a wrap man that's what i was
focusing that's what i was focused on
you know you know we talked about we
wanted to be a part of something we want
to be
do what the other kids were doing i
wanted to do what the soccer players
were doing
i wanted to do what the basketball
players were doing
i see people on tv the nba the the world
cup
i wanted to be there you know i wanted
to be on tv and be a professional
um professional athlete you know and
that's kind of how my mindset was always
growing up
yeah man i mean it's it's interesting
how a lot of these like extracurricular
activities do help people out a lot
that's like what these
after school programs are very important
for a lot of these kids and people don't
even think about that stuff like a lot
of the funding
i i don't know where it goes into
schools but after school programming
is something that i've been a huge
advocate of because there's
some people some kids just aren't really
good at school you know they just need
some other place to be outside of it and
if if you're not going to provide an
area for these kids in bad areas to be
at in a productive environment
they're going to find stupid [ __ ] to do
all the [ __ ] time you know
i you know i'm pretty sure we all grew
up with people who uh
who probably were really bright and
smart people but they just were stuck
with the wrong crowd and they end up in
the bad place
like i remember idahomie who um who
ended up in jail for
jacking cars right jack cars like a [ __ ]
ton and you know back in the day
you jacking cars you get you go to jail
for like five to six years easy
but yeah he had done it so many times he
told me after he got out he kind of
changed his life like kind of found god
and everything
um but he told me his first first night
in prison he
he heard a dude getting raped in his
cell oh god you know
i was like yo what the [ __ ] he came out
of jail [ __ ] yoked and i was like yo
what happened
i was like bro you're [ __ ] number one
you have nothing to do and number two i
didn't want to get [ __ ] by any
[ __ ] inmates
so he had a gang up with a bunch of
asian gangs right which he's he didn't
want
he was jacking cars he wasn't a thug he
was just stealing [ __ ]
so he had to go ahead and pretend to be
something that he wasn't just because he
was so scared and he had to yoke up and
he was all tatted up and [ __ ] when he
came out you know
yeah and i can't imagine the gang lag
from the west coast man it's probably
different from
small rhode island man you it's probably
ooh
ten times more you know what i'm saying
so it's like i get it bro
yeah i mean the gang's like i don't know
too much about gang life now you know
but i just know back in the day just
because a lot of my friends were in it
so you know depending on whatever set
you're from a lot of these like gangs
that people don't know about
asian gangs it's not from like it's it's
them from like asian mafia [ __ ]
so you know specifically out in the east
coast like chinese people people don't
know that's like chinese mafia [ __ ] like
from like
from like early on in in the states when
the first like chinese immigration came
like these people number one were
getting bullied and punked or whatever
so they grouped up because the police
wouldn't come and help them nobody gave
a [ __ ] about these human beings
wow and so these are like gang members
who came from like hong kong
and whatever and they built up these
huge [ __ ] mafia [ __ ] over here and
they
they kind of dealt with like the whole
cocaine and all this other [ __ ]
and all these other like privatized
drugs and that's how it all started and
then you have little factions that
started growing then the young ones
start their own gang young ones start
their own
yeah yeah that's kind of how it like you
know if you grew up in that it's kind of
like
you see that all the time you know your
big brother your cousins are in it then
that's kind of like how how uh how the
water flows right down
and listen i don't see anything wrong
with it like it's all good just just yo
if i didn't do nothing to you please
just could we be cool or at least yeah
um you know i get that respect a lot on
the east coast and uh
you know people that know me and stuff
i'm really thankful to to be on the good
the good side of a lot of the gangs you
know what i mean yeah
but um yeah it's it's a crazy lifestyle
and
it wasn't for me you know yeah so what's
what's your next move now
now that you've so you're are you trying
to get back into the ufc like where do
you see your fight career going from
here
you know that was my biggest problem man
i always looked ahead you know i was
always trying to
all right after this fight i'm going to
do this or i'm going to try to get this
next contract
or i'm trying to get top uh crack the
top ten
you know i'm just chilling bro like i
just fought in november
i won that fight against a tough
brazilian you know
two-time world champion of muay thai he
was
16 and eight and he was a tough fight
i mean you definitely fought different
you you you were a lot more patient in
that fight
yes i i i tried i tried to be smart i
didn't you know
i also had a pro i'll fracture the wrist
without even numbering
does every fighter just go in all [ __ ]
up like i think it's impossible right
like
yeah you're never going to be 100 you
know
and um my wrist was hurting that whole
camp i didn't know it was fractured you
know i wouldn't
took the fight so maybe i went into the
fight if i knew it but after the fight i
find out my wrist has been
fractured for a long time so i was in
the cast
for about eight weeks and i've been
training off the cast now for about
three weeks now and
and i'm i'm hearing that there's gonna
be a car in may so i think that
i will be fighting in may again for xfc
i have two more fights with them
and they treat me good and
i think they have some some some big
some cool plans they're doing some big
things man you know uh
at this point it's like i've been in the
ufc
you know there's bellator there's one fc
this xfc this pfl
i'm just happy to be doing what i'm
doing especially during
this crazy pandemic i still get to train
every day
with the best team in the world i still
get to
um go under the lights and provide for
my family
doing what i love yeah so we'll see what
the future holds for me man i'm just
my main goal is just get the job done
you know i gotta go in there win my
fights and
whatever comes with it it'll come you
know so
you're so you're with att now who's the
head coach over there
the head coach is um the man in charge
is conan silveria
he uh he's in pioneer in mma he's a
beast
uh he kind of overlooks what all the
fighters are doing what all the trainers
are doing
but really it's like there's so many
fighters there's probably about 70
people on the mat every day
so there's a lot of coaches and it
depends you kind of pick your coach or
your coach kind of gravitates to you
so i have like a little muay thai crew
that i work with and then i have a
boxing coach
and then i have my mma coach and
they have classes that go you know they
have two or three classes that go on
every day just for the pros and you can
just kind of pick and choose whichever
ones you
want to do you know that unless you're
in like full camp
you have like a written schedule and you
you follow that schedule but
not without sitting down with your
coaches like listen all right this guy's
a jujitsu guy so i want to actually work
more on my takedown defense
so i'm gonna be working with this coach
and this coach more this
this fight camp you know i mean it's
very professional
and um i see why they're very successful
who who runs their who wants to like jiu
jitsu and grappling program then
oh man i would say this hands down like
i've grappled with a lot of
great people and coach
he is a beast on the ground man he's
like multi-time world champion
um and he's really small man but he
he he just takes it to everyone he'll
he'll enter contests at heavyweight
and he's like maybe five two five three
and he'll do heavyweight contests and
he'll make it to the finals you know
with all the other black belts so
he runs that we have uh the wrestling
coach steve marco he's a golden
uh gold medalist olympian um he's a
beast
and uh we also have mike brown you know
everyone knows who coach mike brown is
yeah
he's from the northeast just like i am
so we click real real well
and um he has a great game plan we have
great muay thai coaches
and um great boxing coaches we have so
many coaches and
all the coaches are so genuine and they
really want what's best for you
you know uh you need something and
they're always there for you
it's nice so you're what you're you're
32 now
i'm 32 yes 32 now how how much longer do
you see yourselves fighting because
i i i mean today i actually just found
out that alistair overeem
and [ __ ] uh jds got cut from the oc
really i saw a junior today he didn't
say anything yeah
he got he got cut so um his contract is
up
i mean obviously he was on a four fight
a losing skid
um which is hard for me to see just
because you know he put on some of the
[ __ ] best fights he was
a tear in the division obviously you
know if anybody who's watching fighting
now
like you look at jds's fight streak
you're looking at an older jds he's
exactly he's in his 40s for crying out
loud you know
but you know what david sorry i keep
hitting my table
no good even if you get cut from the ufc
with resumes like alistair overeem and
jds they can go anywhere
if they want to still fight they can go
anywhere and make more money
they can go to the nfc bellator pfl for
the one million dollar tournament and
make even more money
yeah or even xfc you know what i'm
saying like
so at this point with fighters that have
been there and done that with
a big resume i'm not saying i have a big
resume but i fought in the ufc seven
times you know i've
yeah a couple belts locally i have a
resume i have a name
and you know it it's not the easiest
sell but i won my last fight so my stock
went up
i win two more fights boom i'm back in
there
so is it gonna be a ufc is it gonna be
the xfc is it gonna be one fc i don't
care what the letters say on that
contract now
i'm i care more about numbers so now i'm
fighting for a different reason i'm
fighting to set myself up and my family
up
for the future because i know i i i got
what
i'm 32 now i always told myself i ain't
going to fight till 35 but now that i'm
att
i'm training this way my body feels so
good i don't feel so beat up i feel like
i'm smarter
who knows when i'm done you know um
i'm just enjoying the process as a
martial artist and
just being grateful that i'm on the mats
every day learning from
and and training with some of the best
fighters and the coaches in the world
yeah yeah yeah i was i always wondered
too because you know
i didn't really think about it like that
because now they're they're i want to
say competition for the ufc but there's
options now which is always great for
fighters
very good because before it was ufc
bellator ufc bellator but now there's
the pfl
there's the fight there's a promotion
that you're fighting for there's so many
now exactly
you know and it's and it's good for
fighters it's a lot of exposure like
where i fight as on nbc sports
that's the same channel that football is
on you know basketball's on
and and um that's a huge platform and
one fc is huge and you know all
these promotions are getting so smart
and they're starting to care more about
the fighters and that's why i really
like the xfc you know
they care a lot about the fighters and
they try and do things right by the
fighters so
yeah i'm really happy with that right
now so you're definitely for you
in your stage of maturity you're not
looking to like look for a belt anymore
like that's not
that's not your thing because you were a
champion i mean you know what that feels
like to have that belt
and you definitely if if the time comes
to fight for the xfc belt i would be
more than honored to
but i'm also that type of guy that oh
just because i'm a ufc veteran
i deserve a title shot i don't think
like that a lot of people might
but i don't want that ball i want to
earn that belt i want to get like two
three solid wins and really
earn that belt and fight somebody that
that
you know earned a title shot
you know i don't think that it's fair
that someone just comes in from a
different promotion and fights for the
belt right away
why are you the xfc champion because
you're a ufc veteran that's a totally
different promotion no what can you do
with xfc what can you do in the ufc what
can you do
in bellator i think that that's how it
should be and how do you feel about like
these uh
upcoming fights obviously when this uh
probably post it's already gonna be
there but you know for for example like
arasana he moves up a weight class and
he's already uh uh
entitled contention he's gonna he's a
contender for the for the belt
what do you think about that well you
know how it went down when jon jones um
decided to go to the heavyweight and
then
that that fight that the fight with yon
and um
dominic reyes that that was for like
not even the interim but that was like
for the interim belt you know so
the light heavyweight is kind of looking
for like um new blood right now and
israel has been on the tear and even
though he's been at 185
he's been putting it on the show and
he's the man so i think that he
definitely deserves
going up to 205 and challenging for the
belt you know
yeah plus with my boy so
[Laughter]
i got a bet i got a bad mouth for him
you know what's good
i feel like he really deserves the shot
for sure
when i look at somebody like like john
behold it's like he's he's only an inch
taller than me this [ __ ]
looks like he's six six he's six too
this fool's [ __ ] huge
like what kind of six two human being
looks like that
i tell you what and that man carries
some power
when he kicked dominic ray's once in
that rib and it just turned purple
i was like yo how he'd even turn his hip
on that kick
i was like how hard is this full hit oh
my gosh some some people are just born
with that power man
and you can see the way he lives you
watch that ufc countdown he's in the
snow he's in
you see that yeah he called it spicy
listen i could i could do that probably
take me a couple
but i'll do it for like two minutes
maybe i don't know what my will i
but he does it like enjoying me like
what i would do right i would dig up i
would dig up the hole
and then all right hey you're timing you
better be timing
five minutes i'm jumping in it's not the
clock boom
this [ __ ] is into the [ __ ]
pool while he's shoveling the ice out
the time didn't start yet so i'm like
this guy this guy's just a beast man
he's like chilling in there
you would think like if somebody gave
him a sandwich he would just eat his
whole lunch while he's chilling in his
eyes filling in that yeah
this will said he does that for no less
than five minutes
max 15 and i'm like hold on a second no
less
that means that if it doesn't hit five
he goes i'm not leaving this thing like
i gotta be in at least five minutes
exactly what the [ __ ] is wrong this guy
is a he is a polish warrior he was born
in the wrong way
man i'm such a fan of the sport you know
i have so many friends
and i've trained with so many of the
best fighters in the world that you see
on the ufc in bellator
and i'm so grateful for that and then
sometimes they end up fighting each
other man and you know when something
when sometimes like
things like that happen i just sit back
and i become a fan you know like
speak for instance when kamaru uzman
fought gilbert burns
oh that's amazing i grew up with these
guys in the mma gym
like we all had one dream and that was
to be in the ufc and be a champion
at one point you know and at one point i
had more fights than both of them
yeah and you know it's my kid's birthday
they're over my house their kid's
birthday we're all over at
gilbert's office we're over at kamaru's
birthday party
for his his daughter and then they're
fighting each other
you know and even though i don't train
with them anymore even though i'm with
att
it hurt watching that fight you know but
i had to just like sit back
and watch it i wasn't even gonna watch
it but i just chilled out watch the
fight and
before that fight who did you think was
gonna win
i i would tell people each and
everyone's strength
so i would say gilbert it's more
explosive and
he's i i thought that he had an
advantage on the ground
but camaro had to fight iq
and he had good clinch in wrestling
you know that's what i would say i
didn't know who would win honestly
and nakamura might fight george
masterhog and i seen george maskelot
every day and he
and they all know that i used to train
the black zillions
but that's the cool thing about att like
they ex
they're like yo that's cool bro we can't
change that pass but
you're us now you're att now and and and
that's a special feeling you know what i
mean
george i mean i mean obviously att had
their whole
thing with you know colby covington and
george masvedal and i think that's like
what people are saying now is that well
just because we're on the same team we
got the same goals like if you're just
uh
you're you're going to be a roadblock in
my road to success i got to still take
your ass down
yeah um because it's not just a fight at
the end of the day it's a business you
know when and that
being the champion that changes your
life that just that doesn't just change
your career it changes your life you can
do a lot of things from there you know
even if you lose
as it as um as challenging for the title
your next fight you're getting paid
three four more times and you what you
would
usually get paid you know what i'm
saying and when you watch him
forget about it you're getting paid
maybe like 10 times more
yeah plus endorsement so it's a life
changer man and
and it's not just a fight it's a
business
yeah i mean gilbert burns definitely i
mean
when he hit a camaro with that overhand
that hard ass overhand i was like yo
that's a
lights out punch and then come on he
just stood right the [ __ ] up i'm like yo
this guy's different
like that is a different human being
nobody gets cracked by gilbert burns
like that and stands right the [ __ ] up
you know exactly you know um
those two guys i love them a lot man
they're my
they're both warriors and they're such a
good example not just to me but
to everybody they're around you know um
all the young fighters even the older
fighters that are around them every day
man
um hats off the boat for them man for
sure
yeah but i when i say i love watching um
like all those like the the it was like
anatomy of fighter that's like your old
gym
yeah my boy will harris yeah yeah yeah
you know and i would always see like
kamar husband and michael johnson go
back and forth on each other oh yeah
i'm like are these friends or they
[ __ ] hate each other what the [ __ ] is
going on with these guys
bro and that's how it was every week at
the black zillion not just once a week
twice a week
god damn dude everybody was doing that
everybody's
doing that it's cracking the [ __ ] out of
each other i'm like yo
are you guys friends like and then after
they're hugging i'm like let me tell you
something if any of my friends stalk me
like that don't ever speak to me ever
again
[ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah that that's that
dutch style kickboxing now
they learn over there you know and it's
cool you know it's cool but damn
yeah they went to war men like michael
johnson too like i feel so sad because
of his last loss like i always felt like
michael johnson was somebody that has
all the pieces to be one of the top you
know and look people forget man michael
johnson [ __ ]
cracked pourier yeah he did he's a gamer
he worked so hard too
um i think he's just kind of finding
himself right now
uh but the game's evolving you know he's
being put against all these um younger
fighters
even though his last fight was clay
guida you know
prior to that he was playing a lot of
younger fighters even my teammate tiago
moises you know and
the game just keeps it keeps evolving
keeps evolving and um
he'll be back if michael johnson still
wants to fight like i said he has that
resume
um he could stay in the ufc i know the
ufc loves him
but even if he it doesn't end up working
out for him in the ufc
he has that resume to to be okay
wherever he goes
dude your buddy thiago muy says man his
last fight
i was so impressed right because he's
already a dope fighter right and you
know alexander hernandez has a little
mouthpiece on him
you know that he got his ass cracked off
a cowboy you know
and he's still talking yeah still
talking man and i'm like bro
there's something wrong with him like
mentally like he's not he's not there
yet yeah
like that i think that humble factor is
kind of [ __ ] him up a little bit and
he's not
i mean there's good to have that conor
in you right like it gets you gassed up
puts you in that mindset state but your
skill level has to also match that as
well
but even conor when he loses he knows
you know he's yeah
yeah it's
man like that was a really good fight
match up right just because they're both
really well-rounded fighters
and then thiago though man he was
blocking every single shot and his
counters were [ __ ]
amazing and just to watch him kind of
break alexander hernandez's will
like it was like whatever alexander
hernandez was going to throw he saw it
countered it rolled it off
countercrossed i'm like jesus dude he is
[ __ ]
ripping this kid up and his calf kicks
were killing him oh man i
thiago i got to spend some time with him
in china with him and his wife for three
weeks because we fought in the same car
in china
so um we spent some time together a lot
and i really got close to him and
the kid's five years younger than 27
years old
and he's been doing martial arts since
he was in diapers because his dad
was actually a fighter and um
i think his dad fought one of the
klitschkos oh
really i think yeah crisco's dad or
something or something like that and and
like
that that's how much of a legend his
father is and
i learned so much being around thiago
because of
how disciplined he was you know he knew
this since he was a young age he's a
martial artist a true martial artist and
he just keeps evolving and it's scary
that he's 27 years old
i really think that he has potential to
be a champion one day
you know i mean i i definitely saw it in
that fight especially how well-rounded
he is and also people nobody wants to
take thiago moyes to the ground
like no absolutely you do not want to
take it to the ground so it's like
to see how great his stand-up was which
i knew it was already decent but
to see how well he handled it and number
one he was just
right in front of alexander hernandez's
face he's like bro [ __ ] bring this
[ __ ] i'm gonna tear your ass up i was
like
dude and towards the end of the round he
goes let's go let's do this let's go bro
let's go he's not like that let's go bro
he he wanted it and
he's a product of his environment
because i'll tell you what all those
little rolls
all those little step backs those cat
kicks
we drill that like three times a week
you know we all drill drill drill all
those little movements
three times a week and um it showed man
he put on the clinic and i'm very proud
of him
yeah i mean i mean that fight card
obviously the
the main the main event wasn't that
great but you know which i was kind of
surprised because it was you know rosa
strike and serial gun
but yeah that fight made up for all that
[ __ ] just to watch
how technical and how much of a clinic
you put on it was so good it was such a
good fight i was
shocked how about the pedro munoz fight
too
i thought somebody was gonna die that's
how pedro trains bro
when you go when i'm going to spawn
pedro i gotta get messy right all right
i'm about to spar this [ __ ]
down don't make no mistake so you make a
mistake get get out of there
oh he's such a beast man i love it that
[ __ ]
was throwing only haymakers and i'm like
this was [ __ ] insane
oh his cat kicks were insane
the coaches at att are amazing the coach
cattell cubas i don't know if you saw my
story the other day
sean shelby tweeted history of the cast
kick
katel cubis started teaching it at att
years ago
and and that's the man right there and
if you search katel
cattell on youtube
you'll see how much of a savage he is
like he's the chairman anderson silva
and mother muay thai coach marco horon
just a great
great great group of trainers there dude
man so that well that makes a lot of
sense too just because like
you know everybody's had the calf kicks
have been coming in
i would say in style like within the
last year but to watch like
it's it's hyper effective right even
when we light spar now like i'm just
lightly throwing it out
and you don't have to throw your full
hip in it it's really quick you just
touch it yeah even if it goes chin to
chin
your chin is going to hurt but his chin
is going to hear it even more yeah
it's just it's just the tap tap tap and
then you just kind of see what happens
and it's so it's right there
so it's almost like for me like throwing
like the low leg kick
it's hard to set up because i just don't
see it i don't have enough practice but
it's so much easier to set up a jab
and kind of like tap the the calf kick
in fun sparring light sparring
so when when i saw that i was like oh it
is actually a lot more accessible
it's just i think for you know it's
better to against takedowns too
because it's so high and it's a lot more
hidden
you know like you just can't see it it's
so quick
so i was like watching him get out of
the way
man that fight was so nuts like just
watching the haymakers and those [ __ ]
cav kicks i was like how are
first of all how the [ __ ] were both
those full standing because he was
getting calf kicked too
and he was getting hit
once again 135 division man such a great
division
i was a fan that night you know even
though i trained with pedro i was room
for him i was a fan of both
and i'm probably both both those guys
too i don't know jimmy but damn what a
good fight
man i after that fight i want to see
pedro munoz munoz if he wants to
run it back with cody garbrandt maybe
right just because they were going so
back and forth
like pedro got rocked super hard and
then he pulled it off and then
cracked the [ __ ] out of garbrandt so i i
always wanted to see them run that back
yeah man that that'd be a good one i
don't think he would do that
good cody's uh i mean uh
i'm i'm glad to see him fight a little
smarter i mean especially when he did
that [ __ ] crazy like knockout of the
year [ __ ] off the cage
yeah and that [ __ ] was nuts i was like
dude he's gonna look away that takes
that takes some balls man
you could tell he's a confident guy
because he pulled that off
yeah so for you if i had like one more
question for you if there was one fight
that you could run back which fight
would it be
oh mally fight okay
well i i i work my ass off so bad
and i'll go i'll get back to the ufc
just to get that fight
i want that fight um because i
like i know my potential and i know my
mistakes and i know what i could have
done
you know i don't think could've
should've would've but i know me man
and and um
obviously i knew i was more adorable
than him in a show
and that goes a long way in fighting
people don't think that but
defense wins championships you know now
we might fight iq and a little more
offense bro
it'll be a totally different fight yeah
i'm glad we've seen
how much of a small brat he is too
playing like oh man bro you lost
you lost fair friend square you lost you
know yeah i mean
his like so cheeto vera trains with
uh with team oyama right and i have a
friend uh ron skolsden that trains with
them too
and he always talks about just how
durable cheeto is right he's also just
one of those dudes that are just sturdy
as [ __ ]
yeah just gangster as hell and then you
hear something like
the reason why i disliked sean o'malley
in that fight was because
what the [ __ ] does your ankle have to do
with your ground defense
you didn't get knocked out because of
your [ __ ] ankle you got knocked out
because you couldn't defend his ground
and pound
so he i kind of saw his will break
and he gave up and that's why he lost so
it was
weird for him to say he got lucky it's
like that wasn't luck what does your
ankle have to do with your ground
defense like you got ground and pounded
that's the difference between the
savages and and the fighters like uh
there's a lot of different fighters but
then there's savages that will go down
those deep waters that would literally
put their health on the line
to to try and win the fight you know i
mean like
um and not everybody in the ufc would do
that maybe 10 percent of them
yeah you know we've seen it multiple
times too like you know people didn't
even know before you know
habib's it was it before he fought
gaichi or pory he had he had the mumps
this fool was like with a deadly virus
or a disease and he still kicked ass
right
you see uh your old teammate kamar
oozman phil had a
had two [ __ ] up knees and a [ __ ] up
shoulder and he won a belt
bro he has to walk down the stairs
backwards every time that's [ __ ] nuts
to me dude
like what the [ __ ] how is he doing what
he's doing i have too [ __ ] up needs to
i'm not doing the [ __ ] that he's doing
i'm not going for takedowns or wrestling
people my knees once my knees hurt i'm
like hey guys time out i'm done
like i can't do this [ __ ] that's cool
man
it's great that you're such a fan bro
yeah man i like i
i fighting it to me is one of those
things i really enjoy
not before not for the blood or anything
else like that is because i like
though though i'll always make
commentary about what a fighter does or
says this is from a fan perspective i
know for i know and i know i can't do
what they do
so it's always great to watch fight
that's why i watch prelim fights
whatever it doesn't matter
all these fights have an ability to do
for people to do something amazing
so when i see these fighters come in and
they go into this cage and these guys
are like modern day gladiators all you
guys are modern day gladiators you guys
put it on the line and you put your life
on the line
and anybody who thinks otherwise is only
because you haven't
been faced with somebody who could
literally take your life whatever the
[ __ ] they want
that's why you know there's a lot of
internet warriors you get to mouth off
however the [ __ ] you want without having
a fist in your face
yeah and the crazy thing is is like once
you start training and you get into this
arena
you do get humble because you start to
realize how
small of a fish you are in this big ass
pond right and
i remember just looking back at one of
my old videos right it was when i first
started trying to
to do striking right and i did a kickbox
kickboxing
like when i was 20. and i got my money
taken because i don't know who the [ __ ]
i was signing up for
this was like this is like what 10 years
ago a lot of people just didn't know
what they were training unless you went
to a very specific area with fighters
right so i didn't have a very great
coach so but i took that little one-year
kickbox and like [ __ ] your boy tight
you know i remember i did my first and i
recorded myself and i was like
hey man this [ __ ] video is like in
slow-mo or some [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
i was like yo what the [ __ ] is with this
video i found out how bad i was i was
like yo i'm actually not good
at all not the beauty of it though like
it's great man like i've been training
for what 14 years now i've been fighting
14 years and
bro i get humbled every day because
there's a bunch of savages on that mat
every single day
you know and and um that's just the part
of the martial arts you know
you're never going to be the best and
you're never going to know it all
it's always going to be and you're not
always going to have a good day
you're always going to have bad days and
good day more bad days and good you know
that was the hard part that i realized
like there's days like in sparring where
you're just [ __ ] you feel amazing
right everything's clicking the footwork
is great you're seeing everything
and there's another day where some dude
is just beating your ass that you don't
know why
and you just have to deal with it and
and
but the facts that you do get from like
training
uh where you know what even working out
like you're getting healthy
you know you're doing martial arts
you're learning the art so
that's education right there that's
something that
will never go away once you learn how to
throw a punch
boom you learn how to throw a punch you
pass the class
now you can throw a combination jab
cross hook you passed that class now
you're adding kicks
and now you're mixing up you're sparring
and you're doing okay sometimes
then you pass that class um i look at
martial arts as
education you know like um
you just keep on learning it's a
non-stop education and the more you want
to do
you can stop any time but that's when
your education stops but the more you
keep on training you keep on training
the more you just learn and put into
that toolbox and you might relearn
something and be like oh damn that's the
easier way to do that
especially in jiu jitsu or something oh
i'm gonna do it this way
and and and that's that's why it's cool
and i appreciate talking to somebody
like you who who actually does train
because you know how it is yeah so i
like when i that's what i'm saying like
it's it's always easy for people to
criticize something that they've never
done
and specifically martial arts kickboxing
mma
it's something that you learn a lot
through repetition like
i i like i remember the first time i
started sparring
and i and i [ __ ] uh slipped two
punches and i rolled a hook i was like
when the [ __ ] did that come from like
it's like i've been trying to do that
[ __ ] for two years
yeah yeah and then out of nowhere it
happened and i'm like holy
too i bet it was so natural like you
even think about it no i didn't think
about it at all it just happened i was
like yo what the [ __ ] is going on i'm
like yo this is dope
and you know no matter how many times i
could have read a book about when to
slip a punch
when to roll something is through
repetition and training like they're
talking in the face a couple times right
yeah there's there's no other way you're
gonna find out how this works unless you
actually do it
and i think those little small moments
it kind of what it what builds
confidence and makes you feel good too
it's like
all this work that i've done is finally
paying off so when i sometimes
you know you click on these profiles of
these trolls and they go oh
why didn't he just [ __ ] clinch and
grab him up and then roll up it's like
bro
do you have any idea how hard that is
like you can't
in order for you to slip a punch that
means like instinctually
you you know where that punch is coming
by
is that what they say david ever says
like all that i i don't read no comments
i don't
any of that i just it just cracks me up
because i love clicking on the profile
like i don't i never comment back but it
just makes me laugh because like it's
always some
[ __ ] fat [ __ ] little [ __ ]
[ __ ] made little greasy [ __ ]
you know and he shows a a video of him
kicking a bag and it's the worst [ __ ]
i've ever seen it's like it's only going
to get worse you know because
but it's all good yeah and tell you hey
get punched in the face
now right you know i'll tell you this
training has made
watching the ufc a lot more fun too like
it's been um
because before i couldn't see a lot of
stuff that other people were seeing you
know and i'm just like
waiting for somebody to get knocked out
but now like when i see somebody grab
position i can see what they're doing
especially like on the ground and up
against the cage
yeah i could see what the next moves are
that gets me excited because yeah
that's dope because you're like oh and
then they might do something that you're
thinking or they might do something
totally different you'll be like what
the [ __ ]
yeah it's it's crazy and it just made
the sport so much more fun and that was
like the main reason why
i wanted to start training again was
because i just didn't want to be like
those people who had an opinion about
something when i didn't know what the
[ __ ] i was talking about
and when i went to a usc fight it was
specifically the garbrandt
it was it was a fight with garbrandt
versus um
dillashaw and then mighty mouse versus
yeah it was in la
and then that was the first ufc fight i
had i was like six rows back
and i was like i'm never gonna go see a
fight live again because everybody
[ __ ] next to me
were these [ __ ] armchair experts yeah
you know and they were screaming some of
the stupidest [ __ ] i've ever heard in my
life
and i'm like put them in the face
yeah [ __ ] like that and like this dude
so this is [ __ ] funny so i'm watching
this fight right
and uh there's a guy who clearly bought
this ticket for his girl next to him
right they're on a date
and this fool is literally just spewing
random [ __ ] trying to impress her with
his like fight knowledge
but he literally knows nothing about
fighting and he's like
why is he not just putting him in a
[ __ ] guillotine he'd be lights out
and i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about dude
they're standing up and striking and
exchanging how the [ __ ] is he just gonna
jump on this dude and put a guillotine
on him so he was literally just saying
whatever
and this girl looked at him like he
doesn't watch fighting at
all but a majority of the people in the
crowd are like him
they they just want to see somebody get
killed in the cage
so they don't know what they're looking
at is because they don't train you know
yeah and the sad part is like
but that's what that's what we do it for
you know it's crazy
like we entertain those people but at
the same time they're buying the tickets
and
they're supporting us so it's like you
know i appreciate all the fans
um but you do get a lot of fans like
that for sure
yeah man i mean what you do is a is a
very unique thing man like
getting to know a lot of the fighters
and seeing what you do i definitely can
tell the difference between
what a fighter does and then you know
what somebody else would would do in
your situation and that
the answer is like we can't do what you
do it's it's a mental thing that the
mentality of getting in a cage
and watching people watch you fight
scares the [ __ ] out of me
you know you you almost feel naked
you're fighting you almost feel like i
feel like that sometimes like
i feel naked but i'm fighting somebody
naked
you know what i'm saying and um it's
something that you have to learn how to
get used to you know like
just like anything it's like you get a
lot of anxiety going out before the
fight like
i get my anxiety's at 100. damn i'm
about to fight somebody
yeah okay you're up in three minutes oh
but then it's like all right um
you know for most fighters i'll talk for
myself
if i know i put the work in if i know
that i had a good camp i had
no bad injuries and stuff my mindset was
right i'm confident
you know and that's probably what you
saw in my last fight that's why i was so
confident that's all so calm
because i knew i did all the right
training i knew that i had a good camp
and um that that's just how it is man
like once that cage door closes
all that goes away and you gotta learn
how to kind of just like and i'm still
learning this
you know i mean like it's not something
you could just learn like
i'm still learning this i'm not the
smartest guy in the book you know i'm
saying something i learned to experience
you know i can't just like look at
something oh this person
i'm learning to experience and i'm like
all right you did this long enough so
you got to learn how to just focus and
zoom in you worked hard boom
time to put everything together yeah
and even though even though when you do
kind of
you're still dissatisfied
i mean that's the beautiful experience
of martial arts there's always room to
level up and like you said
you're never going to know everything
even by the time you die
you know and that's the beautiful part
like it's just there's
there's always room for growth and every
time you level up it feels better and
better and better
and i love it man i love it i i can't go
like if i go a day without it
and knowing that i cheated that day if
it wasn't like my day off and i went
i'm not the same person yeah i should do
something
yeah well hey man thanks for uh stopping
by on the podcast is there anything you
want to plug
hey man i just appreciate you uh
putting me on here and uh appreciate all
your support
throughout these years um you guys want
to follow me andre suk mma you know amen
i
i
wish you best on your endeavors man i
appreciate that man thank you
sure all right brother hey all right bro
i'll see you keep in touch
yes sir